we kind of talked about it a little bit
but uh once again a lot of people that
listen to this
have never been on the mat have never
tried jiu jitsu but are really curious
about it
everybody at all positions like i think
elon musk's kids are not doing jiu jitsu
andrew yang is like they're all you know
the world is curious
it's a it's a nice it seems to be
a nice methodology by which to humble
your ego
which to grow intellectually and
physically so people are curious about
it
so the natural question is if they're
curious about it how would you recommend
they get
started maybe like what do you recommend
the first day
week month year first couple years look
like like
how do you ease into it and make sure
that it's a positive experience and
you progress in the most optimal and
positive way
the first thing you can do is is simply
ask yourself why
why you want to be involved and you know
i remember the first day that i walked
into ronan athletics in
new york city to train under um
godfather my son now christian montes
and i didn't know what i was getting
myself into i
played baseball through high school and
i wanted i was at manhattan college
in the bronx and i wanted to go and
learn martial arts because
it was always something that was
interesting to me but it was never
something that that was
i that i knew was accessible and it
definitely wasn't really around in
northern virginia where i grew up
whereas then you stick yourself in
manhattan and there's stuff everywhere
so anyway i guess i didn't know what to
expect um i didn't know
if i was going to get beat up if people
going to be nice if people were not
going to be nice
but what i began with was i think
expectation management
and i think that that's something that
uh i would
that'd be the first thing that i would
start is almost imagining what is it
that i'm getting myself
into because i love the martial arts
with with the martial arts has given me
everything in life and i'm so thankful i
wouldn't be sitting here
um with without without that that
experience that journey of the people
that i've met the place that i've gone
i could never ever have ever imagined um
and i'm just unbelievably thankful for
that but i think that the
thing that um that helped me
most of all was starting with go you
know
my mom said something to me one time and
she said uh you know there's
two types of people in various
situations is why and there's why not
and you know it's understandable to have
questions concerns things like that
um but it may be sometimes a little bit
easier when you're when you're younger
to
just trust people or just say oh no you
know um
but uh we go hey you want to climb that
rock i'm like yeah why not let's go
hey you want to jump in that river yeah
why not sure versus if i have to
reason my way into everything i have to
be talked into everything
a lot of times i'll talk myself out of
it and i think that a lot of times this
is the thinker's disease
you want to figure out what's going to
happen and what you should expect to
have happen
before you get involved versus going
using the old bruce lee saying again
it's like no amount of thinking or
training on the on the side of the river
will teach you how to swim
you have to jump in and there are risks
associated with that and
so i guess uh psychological are usually
the biggest ones that's the biggest
hurdle
and physical um but the biggest thing
that i guess i would suggest to anyone
to say why do you want to do this you're
like well i want to challenge myself i
want to learn
i would like to learn to fight i wanted
to learn to fight so that i could
protect myself and if and if anything
else other people if only within arms
reach
i perceived that if i had some small
degree of power
i generally wouldn't use it which is why
i was like i'll give it a try i'll try
to be reasonable and hopefully if i make
a mistake i'll apologize to people but
basically uh
i said yeah i'd like to have that and
i wanna i know this is gonna be
challenging and we'll see what happens
and that means that getting beat up and
i didn't get like hurt but getting
roughed up and getting my arm
bent this way or that way getting choked
i was like well this is all supposed to
happen that's no big deal
it would be like going and joining the
army during peace time
and then going i'm just doing this for a
college education you go like okay
that's cool man
and then all of a sudden war breaks out
and they want to send me somewhere and
i'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa i didn't
sign up for that gig actually you did
whether you realized it or not you may
not have thought that you did but you
did
so getting your mind right and and just
going what are my expectations
this activity what is it that i'm
looking to do and of course you know
you're you're going into a gym you're
going into a place that you don't know
people
you probably don't know people and you
don't know the coach and even if you do
want to hey how you doing shake your
hand type of level
you know 95 percent of my students don't
know me not really you know i'll try to
be polite and not annoy them too much
but they don't know me and i don't know
them
um i understand if they don't trust me i
wouldn't trust trust me either
if i were them but at the same time
someone has to take that leap
and one of the things that i've noticed
um as a martial arts instructor that's
the biggest struggle
uh with dealing with adults which is why
a lot of people like to teach kids is
because kids don't ask don't argue
now that also means there's there's all
sorts of pitfalls with that sort of
thing and that can be an issue
but you know i guess a lot of times
people get to a point in their life you
know in their
20s early 30s where now i'm i'm a
manager now i know what i'm doing no one
talks to me like that
yeah versus like hey man you go join
boot camp i don't care if you are elon
musk they're gonna try to shut up and do
push-ups yeah and that's
what's great about it yeah um so you are
taking a leap of faith
into a world that you're gonna be a tiny
fish and you gotta hope that the people
um who are who are guiding you in that
in that journey are gonna have
i can't say even say your best interests
at heart because they don't even know
you but they'll try to do no harm and
they'll try to help you in the way that
they would understand
and i guess that's for instance that's
what i would try to do with anyone
that that comes into my gym i would try
to help them in the way that i
understand
they need as best i can and as safe and
reasonable a way as possible
but sometimes in a way that's going to
make them uncomfortable particularly if
physical combat
and and it's not something they've done
before um if they've a lot of people go
in without even having played
you know contact sports and so that can
be a big jump and you have to understand
if if that's
where you're starting from no worries
but you're going to have to kind of work
your way to it and it's going to be
uncomfortable and it'll and that's okay
it's part of the process and you're
going to have some bumps and bruises and
you're not going to want to roll with
that guy in the corner because that that
person's rough and they beat you up and
they're like okay but
is this a big hurt or is it a little
hurt if it's a big hurt
okay if it's a little hurt you need to
just
drop a little bit yeah it's such an
interesting balance because
to find i think one of the most
important things
as in anything i think in life is the
selection of the people or that you put
around you
i mean that's true with the like getting
married that's true with uh
like if you go to if people ask me like
graduate students
like your phd advisor can um
can be the difference it's everything
it's like
you spend five years with somebody
they're going to basically define
the more impact on you than anybody you
marry anybody you hang out with is a
huge impact and the same with the
the coach selection which is
like the school selection is it's going
to be really important about in terms of
like who you select
will uh define how happy like
the trajectory of your growth and how
happy you are with the entirety of the
experience and yet
like the the flip side of that is
especially if you have an ego especially
if you are the manager then you need to
let go some stuff
you're going to feel like [ __ ] with the
good with the best kind of coach
that's that's what you need right but
there's a nice there's a weird balance
there
to find like i i mean like and everybody
needs a different thing like i'm much
more
uh i enjoy being sort of like
sounds weird but like i am you know from
the wrestling background
i enjoy feeling like crap in the sense
like the coach
like getting beat up i don't actually
enjoy it it's not like some masochistic
thing or whatever
it kind of like it's the growth like i
like the anxiety i like uh feeling uh
like like [ __ ] when i go home like
emotionally
physically it's like it's growth it's a
sign of growth right like if you're not
having to feel those things you're
probably in your comfort zone which is
fine but that's not your growth zone
right and everybody has a different
threshold for that and you i mean the
the beautiful thing about jiu jitsu is
like
it's also has like a yoga feel to it
like you're learning about your body
so depending on the gym and depending on
in fact
the coaches the people around you within
the gym you can select little groups too
kind of like the people with who you
roll like if you're a smaller person
it doesn't mean you have to go against
big people you can go against the people
who like
smoke a lot of weed and they're chill or
you can go against like that crazy
ripped blue belt competitor who's like
out to destroy everybody
and depending on like what your mindset
is you can kind of select that
it's such a fascinating journey
of like basically self-discovery i
couldn't agree with you more it's
been what you need may change over time
right maybe what you needed
what you need today could change six
months from now or a year from now and
that's something that i
experience i'll use my uh first coach
christian again as a great example of
someone who i really
look up to and respect and someone who
helped me a lot like at a time when i
really needed some guidance and i needed
to learn
martial arts but get into i henzo
gracie's gym was right down the street
from where christian was teaching
and christian was a blue belt at the
time it was uh he was teaching at a
place called fight house which is this
awesome
like you know like 90s early 2000s
you know warehouse area down on fashion
avenue in uh
in manhattan off of like between seventh
and eighth and uh it was like
like two basketball courts why but like
there was the [ __ ] guys over here there
was the kali guys over there there was a
wing chun over there with jits in the
corner
and hence was one of the most famous
academies in the world at that time
still is
and i just didn't know what enzo gracie
was and i mean
it's a great gym and it's a fantastic
place for people to train but i think
what was right for me at the time
was to i stumbled into a you know like a
two-person elevator
up and found a place where six people
trained at that time
and i had someone that that i could that
could give me some
like in addition to martial arts advice
like personal guidance
and that made it that made a big
difference and then one initially we
would have like competitions or like
intra
intra you know gym competitions with the
[ __ ] guys we would comp we would roll
with them
and like again it was great because they
were just a bunch of like like russian
dudes from like brighton beach and they
would come down
and then we would all fight and then
everyone would train and we'd all drink
tea and then go home
and uh anyway uh what was uh
it was super super tough and they were
like again just a tough group of people
it was great
and then i remember when i decided after
like four or five months i'm like man i
really want to try to take this
seriously and i told christian about
that and he's like well hey i think you
need to do the following and it was
you know like hey here's there was a guy
named jeff ruth who was uh
about at the time which was a much
bigger deal than it is now but it was
10-0 as an mma fighter a lot of amateur
boss spirit super tough dude
and jeff was was the best person at that
time that i'd ever trained with and i
just got squashed christians beat me up
too but like
jeff would just absolutely kick the crap
out of me and i was like this is awesome
and this was back when i was at home i
went home for the summer for that and
chris is like hey i think you should
stay
because i told him that's what i was
thinking and this was a coach that
you know when it's like when initially
was exactly what i needed and then he's
like well hey that's not what i'm doing
here
maybe they're going to be able to help
you onto a path that's that's kind of
commensurate with what your goals are at
the moment
and then you know that was a niche that
was an interesting thing and i really
got i feel that i was fortunate to start
um at a place where my coach was able to
transition roles
and and and do so comfortably and i
think that that also
was probably a factor the fact that you
know where he'd done some of his
training prior like there'd been issues
with with the coach there we're like not
supporting not having the support
you know feeling like hey like i'm gonna
hold on to my students i'm gonna hold on
to my best guy or my best girl even if i
can't
take them where they need to go
you